nevertheless
you wrote the essay why i'm not
not going to vote this time or ever yeah
i think i won't vote this year or
any other year or any year uh and the
basic idea i hope you do a better job
reading it than you just read that title
i guess you'll take as many takes as
necessary
[Laughter]
i'll read it in russian and then pay
somebody to just translate it
uh this isn't even russian at all you
just make up words
where'd you find this guy um
you get what you pay for exactly
this is anarchy this is what you wanted
uh like your basic summary is uh let me
see
if pressed the simplest explanation i
have for refusing to vote is this
i don't vote for the same exact reasons
that i don't take
communion no matter how admirable he is
or how much i agree with him the pope
isn't the steward
over my soul nor is any president the
leader of my life
this does not make me ignorant or evil
any more than not being a christian
makes me ignorant to evil
if i need representation i will hire the
most qualified person to do so
yeah isn't voting our current best
developed way of hiring the most
qualified person to represent you on
some things
no because because if i have a lawyer
and the lawyer screws up i can fire him
if i vote for someone i don't get who i
want i get for
who my neighbors want so what that makes
no sense representation means
i want you to speak for me whereas
voting is like
i kind of want you but i'll take what i
can get and i'm going to take what i
could get regardless so what's the point
what in governance again that's what
with bitcoin
is you want to be represented in
deciding
what to do but once wait bitcoin isn't
picking a person
they're not picking a president of
bitcoin they're picking an idea yeah
it's more like a referendum
right and to me a referendum is much
more represent is much more coherent and
defensible than it is voting for
representative because
if i'm voting for joe biden i'm saying
this person speaks for me for abortion
taxation environmental policy
immigration war right
the odds that unless you're a complete
npc that this one person
will speak for you for everything and
will and will deliver what he promised
as and has the power to deliver what he
promised is not true whereas if i have
brexit if i say i want britain to be
remain
part of the european union to say yes or
no question that makes a lot more sense
to me
but even that is not pure democracy
because going back to the idea of the
circulation of the elites which
james burnham talked about pareto and
moscow and all them you're still going
to have someone
telling you what you can and can't vote
for and how these questions are framed
so in contradiction to what the left
anarchist said
some element of hierarchy is always
going to be inevitable
so listen i agree with this aspect
very much so that we should be voting
for ideas and issues not voting for
leaders for for leaders to represent us
across
the full spectrum of issues right it
seems to make no sense
okay good man this is great but i do
think there should be um
leader i i do believe in voting for
representatives to
debate to be communicators of ideas to
us but that you here's
here let me start interrupt you but you
can you could you could have those two
things for example wouldn't this be an
improvement if
they have that now you have a referendum
do you want tax rate to be 30 or 40
whatever percent yeah
you have the guy leading the campaign
for 50. fight for 50.
then you have the lady leading the
campaign for 45 for 40 they'll go out
there they can have debates they can
talk about the issue
but you're still not voting for one of
them you're voting for the issue that
makes much more sense to me
then i'm going to vote for him and hope
that he puts forward 50 and that depends
on 99 other senators
exactly and but but also i mean i do
like the idea of voting for certain
people to debate certain ideas yes
right i think that's that's a major
improvement but the final vote should be
based on the idea so
okay so we agree that would be nice to
have plus no wars
and then then uh you'll stop tweeting so
uh
aggressively and to decriminalize things
that don't
hurt people drugs crimes drugs
especially prostitution
is a big one if there's and this is me
talking mr
mr all cops are criminals there's no one
or maybe
other than like abused children who
needs access to the police
other than sex workers they're the ones
who are the most likely to really put
themselves in dangerous situation
so they need to be able to call security
because that's why they have pimps
because you're a woman dealing with some
strange dudes who are
a lot of the time going to have weird
kinks you want to be able to be sure
even if you don't approve of
prostitution think it's horrible that
she's not going to be raped and murdered
and have no consequences
and if you're gonna say oh well she's a
prostitute she can't be raped
i just think for a second if you're
agreeing to sleep with somebody
and then he starts choking you and
beating the crap out of you and saying
it's now it's a dom situation
that is clearly a beyond the pale
assault and the same thing with drugs
uh heroin cocaine you crack
do you um the people that need
help the most are the ones who are
addicted to those drugs even the ones
who need punishment let's suppose you
think drug dealers should be
in jail right it is very hard for me to
say that
someone who sells uh cocaine should be
treated or in the same building
as someone who rapes children or is a
murderer these are not similar types of
evil even if you believe that that drug
dealer is an evil person
yeah i have um i mean there's an essay
in there called
by alexander berkman who's emma
goldman's partner crime on crime
on prisons and crime and this is leftism
at its best
for getting the person who's forgotten
and the fact that we have the world's
largest prison population
the fact that so many people are just
like oh you commit a crime just put them
in jail throw away the key
at the very least if you want to be
totally immoral about it's expensive
and second of all the the concept that
all criminals should be locked in a room
together in these kind of
largely inhuman conditions and that's
going to help people i don't think that
that's the ideal
mechanism yeah i tend to believe i
usually don't
speak so negatively about politicians
but i i do think that
politicians have done more evil
in the war on drugs than did the people
that are supposed to be the criminals
in this picture and i'll give you one
another example of how this is the
anarchist critique of power
hunter biden and i'm not gonna i'm not
making fun of him i'm not thinking shout
out to him
he had an article in uh the new yorker
where he talks about when he was in la
he was buying crack
and there was a misunderstanding or like
he left the crack pipe in the hertz car
and then blah blah there's an issue
he's admitting to a felony in writing to
a reporter and
i'm sure this was within the statute of
limitations there was no possibility
he was going to have consequences kamala
harris who was a cop
talked about when she was in college she
was smoking weed
and it's like i don't begrudge you guys
smoking your crack or smoking your weed
but
for other people who are poor or maybe
just had the
short end the stick this is years of
their life being
destroyed at the very least even an
arrest is a traumatic situation
yeah if you have a weed or cocaine or
crack you're arrested that's really
going to screw up
it's going to do a number on you being
locked up so to have that double
standard to me is completely
unacceptable
and that has nothing to do with the
republican or democrat that george w
bush was uh
i i coke head back in the day he talks
about overcoming his addiction and i'm
glad that he did more power to him
but just to have this kind of you know
it's just really kind of um disturbing
to me and this is my anarchist brain
like how prevalent drug use is in
college there's that i think this joke
on south park like there's a time and a
place to try drugs and that's called
college where people experiment
but all those college kids which are
going to become next generations elite
don't really have that worry that if
they get caught then anything's going to
happen to them
but that kid in the street who did not
have that good upbringing
even if he's a piece of crap like he's
not going to have a different punishment
i i think that's just really
that is based on american
you